have you ever let someone pee
for you what are you like you're
what do you pee in their mouth and then
they pee later the girl stands behind
you
oh and holds it yeah well don't do it
it's terrible i don't care i don't think
so
i don't know why that would come up some
sort of intimacy
that's a thing where i'd be like oh we
need to break up
yeah i know but i'm like maybe maybe how
lazy do i want to get
[Applause]
oh so it's more of a curiosity yeah yeah
yeah i just wanna try
that i get and i was like yeah
whatever and it was weird it was
terrible
now did she dig in and get it and
everything where did you let's get it
out and like introduce well i mean it's
very
first of all with her she
she thought it was so funny
[Laughter]
no one wants that she was like this is
so funny right i'm like
no it's not [ __ ] no this is serious
business
every one of these has been enjoyable
until just
you just stand here and hold it it's so
funny right i'm like
no no and then she started going it's
holding a fork funny she was doing this
being me
she wants this super funny dude were you
at a urinal that we were in
our place so she's just peeing all over
the floor no no she got oh
yeah oh [ __ ] what that's weird
it was so banana like it was a toy
yes making noises and [ __ ]
bang right sweetie
tune the
worst thing because she knows i'm
terrible
with impersonations so
she is also terrible
and she gave me a luke i am your father
and i go don't say that to me
when from your behind
i'm like do you understand how terrible
that
is because she had been pretending it
was a lightsaber
and i was like this is so terrible
but it wasn't good oh
that was that was funny it was terrible
sorry yeah man but i was just
i was just just a psa you know what i
mean just in case you
anybody out there was like you know what
i'm gonna do tomorrow
don't do it
[Music]
[Music]
you